okay
so
that today we'll talk about uh business
report with armageddon what's the name
of the of the meet up and we will see
how to better sim reports
um
so
uh there was already a quick
introduction but i'm i'm from france so
it's like here it's a light diminished
it's it's normal
for me um
and so i'm working as a software
engineer at our studio in the armageddon
team so with usc on
every armageddon related package really
so what are we talking today uh i
put myself in like previously i worked
in an organization before joining rtu i
was working in industry
and often the question was so i work in
an organization i have some guidelines
color phones things like that and i
would like to use them with my
armageddon document because by default
our margin will give me the same
document as
everyone else so how does that work can
i do that with our magnum and so today
i'll try to cover that there will be i
will cover a lot of grounds
so there will be a lot of things it may
not be as
it may not go
as into details as some of you uh
may want but hopefully you will learn
you will learn some stuff
so um
first the the thing to know is
i wanted to remind you about our
magazine and what happens when it
renders
hopefully everyone knows about
armageddon here at the meetup
but a quick reminder our magnum is a
tool to mix text code and render to some
outputs and several outputs using the
same source so
you may know this illustration by alison
arts and it illustrates the way that
sometimes a magnet can appear like magic
you just write text file and you get a
styled output html a pdf or even a word
document
and so it can be a magic but really it's
perceived magic and you need to
understand what is
under the hood if you want to customize
the default behavior and styling is part
of that
so
what happens when it renders
it's a workflow of different tools
you are writing a rmd file
and the first tool that will
work is nitr
nitto is an or package that will execute
the code in your rmd document to put
that into a standard text md document so
a margin text file
and so it will
execute the code and keep the source
code and the result depending on the
option
uh
you will do and so it allows to
programmatically
create some content in a markdown
document
and after that it will be penndot
pendock it's an external external tool a
universal converter and this is the tool
that will allow to convert to pdf to
html to office document and a lot of
other formats
and armageddon is the art packet that
will organize the work of those
different tools
so
this is magic this can be magic because
you are working only with armageddon and
you don't know what happens but when you
want to style and output
usually you need to know
what will be your output so if you want
to style html it's not the same thing as
styling pdf and it's not the same thing
as styling of his documents
so it's why i wanted to remind
of that because
sometimes it can be it can be tricky
there is a lot of things that you can do
that are generic in our magnum document
but when you want to do specific things
for an output sometimes you need to
to know about
new skills and new specific stuff from
from this output
so let's talk about style now
the first format that i want to talk
about is
html output
and for html output styling goes through
css so css means cascading style sheets
uh some of you may know that already
this is a web technology and it's it's
paired with html html is the code that
structure your web page and this is what
you write in the text file and so with
our magdon you are you are writing
markdown syntax plus r code and pen doc
will transform that html for you
but if you want to style your um
your html page and then you want to to
change how it lays out on the screen
you need to use css
if you open a html file
you will see that it is just text and
what you see in the browser it's a mix
of html then css and javascript
so styling html output will require your
more or less css skills so we'll see
that it can be
you will need
a lot of css skill or just a few css
depending on what you want to to style
so if you want to use that in your
organization you will need to use css
either your organization is
already using css and they can proven
you directly with some css snippet but
otherwise you will need to
learn a bit and adjust
from your guideline
so how to use css with our magnum
document
css looks like that so
it's it's a language where you define
some rules and you set some
some value
some values and a knitter as
have as sorry a css chunk engine so you
can put that directly into your magnum
document without any external file so
it's pretty simple to do and it's useful
for prototyping or for quickly iterating
or changing value in documents and so i
use that often when doing demos or
or those type of documents so here
this code means that
i want to apply a specific style so a
blue box
with text center into it on a component
that will have a class
my box on the document and you will see
later how it looks like
and i want and the second rule is
i want that any bold text inside this
box to be also blue so the same cooler
as my border so this is how i can style
differently than the default because
this style is definitely not default in
rmd document
so you could use css
but as you see i'm repeating the
i'm repeating the blue color that could
be the color of my organization or i'm
repeating some uh
duplicating some rules in the document
and so can i do that more efficiently
like a programmatic language like i can
do function in r
and so in fact you can do that
using
a web tool which is called sas
that exists since a long time but that
recently has been available
uh in r uh from a package with the same
name so the sas package so first what is
sas
sas is a css
extension
um language that allows to create
rules and variables for example so it's
pretty useful to use it for for
variables but you can do a lot of things
and very advanced stuff
using function or even operation in your
style sheet so if you know about css
already you know it can be
it needs to be pretty simple it's just
key values
associated but with um
this extension language you can
do some operation inside your style
sheet so what does it look like
this was my css
uh to produce this css i can write
um
scss file
so you see it's a bit different
and the main advantage and what it is
and why it is useful even from for
beginners using css is that you can use
variables
so usually in an organization when you
have a guidelines you have some
main color
secondary colors and you have like a set
of
three to five color that you should use
in your document and using these
tools you can put those values into
variables and then use those variables
in different place for your style sheet
like if you want one color to be used
for all your headers plus a some border
and another color to be used for strong
text for example you you can change that
and so
this um scss code
um
looks like the css but is using variable
like it's starting with a with a dollar
and this will produce the same this css
and so you can use that also directly
into knitter and into rnd document
because uh
anita support the
scss end line and so writing that into a
chunk
will apply
the style for you you don't have to know
anything about
compiling a css document and
and and
building the the css file you just have
to write that in the document and it
will
and it will work
and and this worked um in our through
the sas r package
and the support is now built into our
magnum so
there is an ital engine but it's now
built in also into a modern so i put the
link
to the
package on the website where you will
find a lot of information
and what does it mean to be built in it
means that
the css field that you may know about in
html document you can pass directly
a css file a sass file and our markdown
using the sas package will do everything
for you so that the style apply
in the document
so this could be a great way to have
a sim file that you can use across
different outputs or a sim file that you
can exchange between colleagues or maybe
your organization already have
already has
some sas file
that that you can use
so
using this technology will make it
easier because you can use variables you
can use some functioning rules so
it surely needs
new skills if you don't know about that
but if you plan to customize reports
regularly
because you need to provide report every
week every month and it's not just one
shot and and if you have time to learn
new skills
it's a great way to do that
um
the fact is you can also
um
apply custom scenes to your content
this is something that
maybe a few people know about but there
is a special syntax
inside inside armagnan that is powered
by penndot
that allows you to create custom blocks
for example here what i put and you see
you may recognize the blue box that i
put the css before by creating
this syntax in my rnd file so using the
three columns
then the class name i will create a
component that has
the class mailbox
and if you remember the css i had before
i had something that applied on any
component with this class and so
uh
armageddon using pen doc will transform
this to html you don't have to write the
html yourself and the css that you have
written will apply and so you'll get the
blue box with the centered content
so the so with this you can you
you you see that you can
apply css on already
existing component on your page but you
you also can customize specific part
on the content and you can also do that
using an inline component using another
syntax that you see in the first chunk
which is called bracketed span where you
can put the class and specific element
and and by doing that so i i put an
example with another css i apply a
background on some text just using
syntax in my documents
so you can customize a lot of things
using this technique but it can be
still a bit complicated if you don't
know css and you are not like at ease
with those technology
and
um you can go like further and simpler
with bootstrap
uh in the past two years um our studio
has developed a new package called bslib
which is tools to customize bootstrap
and bootstrap is used in a lot of our
our formats and a lot of our tools
so it was developed by the shiny team by
carson sievert
and
this will allow to customize documents
more easily because you don't have to
know css or sas
this is now supported in our magnum it
will be supported in flex dashboard the
new formats from googdon that you may
know about which is called bs4 book is
built on bootstrap for using a bslip
package and it's also supporting in
supported in
dt
to style stable and in shiny and in the
next package on version so the aim for
us is to use this tool
to provide a consistent streaming system
across our different
format that are using the bootstrap web
library
our magdon still doesn't use vsd by
default but you can activate it
pretty easily using the sim yamaki as
you are seeing in the example and so you
may already know the boost watch team
like i've put an example with the
ceiling
team
here
sim here
so this will activate
the use of bslib and
activating bsc will
allow to customize the sim using only
yaml header so this is pretty
interesting in in
later version of armadan maybe
next version of the one after that we
will make the slip the default in our
magnum uh either be put with bootstrap
three um as today or maybe we'll use uh
the bsc default which is currently
bootstrap four and will be five
pretty soon
so
i won't go into details on how that work
but this is what i can put in my
yaml header
so i'm not writing any css file i'm not
writing any scsh trunks or things like
that i'm putting everything into my yaml
header but i can change colors on
specific elements
of my webpage
so those variables are not
random they are the ones supported in um
in in bootstrap so you have tables in
the bsc package on the website where you
can find all the variables you can
customize so it requires a bit of
reading documentation and know about
that but usually you want to modify
some of those values like the primary or
secondary color to change the main color
of the page because everything else will
be kind of calculated but if you want to
change first pretty specific elements
you can so here in the example i'm
changing the main color
the primary and the secondary color i'm
i'm styling specifically the block code
border to yellow uh i'm creating a
variable called light blue that i will
apply on on the
the inline code color and on the border
of my code blocks i'm also setting the
width of the border to to increasing the
width and changing the color for
warnings and info block in my document
and i'm also increasing the adding
font weight
and
changing the font on my
on my document so you can do a lot of
things and hopefully using one of those
or several of the values you will be
able to create and to to tweak the
document to
be coherent with your organization
guideline
and
using that in an other document would be
as easy as uh copy pasting the yaml
header or storing that uh in into a file
because you can put
those things into a
specific yaml file shared across your
your document it's arm argument features
and so doing that in my level we
render
this kind of document
so you can see so this is a basic
document uh
it's not i've put the links when you
will have links to presentation you will
be able to download the rmd source and
the html output
and so you see that the editor have a
bigger font weight that i get the blue
color on my code
chunks
the primary color is applied on the link
i get the yellow vertical rules for the
block clothes
and also i
i changed color for the warnings and i
created the text using warnings and
creating a specific box
because one advantage of using bootstrap
to style document is that since
bootstrap 4 and it's white bslb
is really useful to styling documents
there is a lot of specific classes and
specific tools that you will find in
bootstrap documentation that you will be
able to use in your in your document
um
so
the html part was a bit uh a bit long
because this is the main document that
usually people do
um with
with our magdon and and you will find
some useful resources in those different
websites see what is going on and what's
already exist
so in the remaining time we will go more
quickly on
office document and then pdf document so
because in organization
often
there is still
word and powerpoint documents that are
used
and it's interesting to know that you
can customize those when you are
creating these with armageddon
so customizing a powerpoint presentation
or word document is as easy as providing
a reference doc
and so to create the template this
reference document there is one way and
it's my advice if you want to try it
is that you should render
the document without providing any
reference doc
this will output a powerpoint
presentation or a word document and you
save this document as a template
and then you can modify this reference
document to change the style
uh to customize the color to customize
some of the things that word and office
lets you customize and then you can use
this document as a reference
this is one way of doing it obviously
you can use your own templates if you
have that but you need
the mechanism that
this is powered by pen dock and so the
mechanism relies on office styles
so
here is a quick screenshot of
what it means to modify a style in
in office
i hope this is big enough but
this rely really on the on the office
style so uh if you style your worm
document by just selecting the text and
changing the color of the text for
example
color of the font and things like that
it's not really styling styling in
office is
having a name styled apply on a
paragraph and apply on the text
that are two style at the same time so
here this is an example of modifying
the paragraph style for my second level
editing so the first step is to place my
cursor into a second level heading
and open the style pane and the style
pane this is on the left
will have uh you'll see that the blue
box show what is selected so this is the
heading 2
style currently and i will right click
on this and modify and by doing that
there will be a modify style pen
and paint and ear i will be able to
change the color or add the border or do
or do things things like that
and
then i can click ok save my template and
use it in the document and what will
happen when you will render using this
template is that
the heading 2 style that is put on
second level header will be the one that
you have in your template so this is the
way you can style
docx and and powerpoint outputs
and the same way that with html you are
able to to apply custom time on specific
part you can use the same type of syntax
for
for word and powerpoint using a special
attribute called custom style so by
doing that i'm i'm applying on on the
left i'm applying a special highlight
box
custom style
to my text that i can um tweak in my
templates so that it applies so you will
be able to download the rmd source and
the template and see
and see how the results look like but it
will be
a style with a with a colored box and
something text in the middle so i put
link to documentation this is
this is powered by pen doc
and this is the main document this is
the main limitation
with
this
with this styling
is that we are limited by the features
that pen dock supports for styling
um office documents so not everything
can be customized sometimes it can be
pretty limited it depends on what your
organization is using
if it's using a
very complex
template or if it's just some guidelines
on what your document should look like
um know that we are trying to improve
this we work this summer we spend our
tip to improve the point completing
mechanism so hopefully it will become
easier in the next version when we are
doing something in pandork it needs to
be released in pandora then it needs to
be available in the r studio ids than in
our markdown so that you can access it
but
soon it will be it will be easier
but unfortunately styling office
documents is not really easy
pen doc or not because one must know
about the office style system and from
my
previous experience in my organ previous
organization i know it's not
not everyone knows that and sometimes
people send you templates that are
really
like
dummy documents to fill in and not
really template to use
as style because they just put some
headers in color and define custom style
in the document but if you are using
simple customization that should work if
you are using complex one maybe not
so no if you are
an av office user know that there are
other tools in the our community mainly
the office verse by david goel with the
officer package and the office done
package so officer officer is about
manipulating an office document from r
and office don is
is using our magnum to use officer to
create
powerpoint
and word presentation so you can be
interested by by those package
and lastly about pdf document if you
really want that
because you need to produce some reports
and send them in pdf
it's often not easy
because producing pdf the main usage is
using latex and so as i said when you
want to style an output you need to
style it by
the technology that is used to create it
so
pdf will be created by latex and you
need to use latex to style
to style the documents so there is some
uh specific latex package that you can
use sometime it could be helpful if you
if you
if you
already
played with articles package or if you
already written market latex you know
about that if you don't
maybe it's not as important to invest in
it because there is a new way to create
pdf it is through html and the good news
is that you can use css in that case
so you can use the same technology to
produce html and to produce the pdf and
there is two solutions to create pdfs
for html the first one this kind of
simple one is printing the document as
is
it means like if you are using chrome
for example there is a good printing
function
but the drawback is that it will print
the document
as you see on the screen so usually a
web page is linear it can be very long
and it can be not suited to be printed
on a4 formats or paginated document
but the second solution is to format and
style the html specifically for printing
a document to pdf or or through
paginated format using what is called
page media css
and the good news is that there is an
our package for that which is called
page done i don't give much example i
just wanted to share that with you in
case you don't know about it
page join will allow you to create
paginated html and it brings basically
it brings
a pgs
libra javascript library toolbar
which is used to create
a paginated content so by paginated i
mean that when you will open the html on
the screen it will look like some pages
that you can see and the pages is
defined by margin is defined by header
footer
um
a page number usually a running header
something like that so you can really
create
paginate content using html and if you
are interested i would suggest that you
look at the
talk by uh on our studio conf 2019 which
was the where page done was announced
um
as an example
um
i wanted to show you this so what you
can see on the left
is the resulting document that you can
create using page done so this document
is created using page report which is a
community package developed by
thomas roland and david case
and
they wanted to simplify the use of page
down
through templates because page down is
really the core tools to customize
but um
[Music]
there is
some templates included in it but if you
want to make a template specific to your
organization that look like that it
could be a good amount of work and what
they did is provide template where you
can change some part of the template
look at the colors the fonts the cover
um or the logo so it can be a good way
to start with
with this and
as examples to see
how you can create such templates
that was a lot of information
so
we we've seen how to customize html
output
uh using different technology we've seen
how to use templates mainly with office
outputs
uh we've seen that
you can create custom parts in your
document using margin syntax
specific modern syntax
and we've seen that
pdf can also be customized
for your organization if needed
what you need to remember
is that this is just the beginning for
for some time there was no easy solution
css was the only one for html recently
it's easier through the use of sas and
bslib and hopefully it will be easier in
the years to come because we are working
on a better html theming system in the
magnet team and in our studio
also mainly because bslib will be only
useful if you are using a format that
chooses bootstrap but we want to make
the seaming system using yammer or any
other mechanism a simple mechanism so
that you can use the same scene across
different type of outputs so we are
working on that still thinking about it
but but we will continue to improve
based on your feedbacks and based on
on
on on what we we know and try to
contribute to penndot also
because we think that seeming report is
uh something really important
uh so that you can differentiate for
other and usually in corporate world
it's it's important to have to stick
with guidelines and
and
things like that so
thank you
awesome thank you so much kristoff
i'm seeing quite a few questions that
are coming in
in both the zoom chat and on slido
so just a reminder to everyone if you do
have questions
if you don't mind just using the slido
link it will help us organize them all
but let me head over to the slido and
start to ask some of the most upvoted
questions there
and one that came in was can params be
used to reference variables for
powerpoint outputs
sorry can you
i'm not seeing this yeah
so
one of the questions was can params or
parameters be used to reference
variables for powerpoint outputs
uh you can use uh parameters for
powerpoint outputs
but
um
i don't think it will help you style
specifically
the powerpoint output because you will
need to use a template to style the
outputs the parameter will allow you to
modify some content or to
dynamically
include or
or choose what to put in your
in your document
thank you
and just a note to everyone if it's your
question that is asked and you want to
jump in and add any additional contacts
feel free to to unmute yourself as well
um the second uh upvoted question was
how far can styling go before it is
considered not much better than chart
junk
the
the parts of like really the aim of all
these and it's why it was um i presented
that using the business report with
armageddon it was the
topic of the
of the meetup is usually you need to
style when you need to stick with
guidelines or you need to stick with an
organization or you want to
differentiate from other
but
don't style just for styling or to make
things fancy
it can be like chart indeed
but
sometimes it's important that
you can change the color or you can you
can communicate using your organization
guidelines because otherwise
you may not be able to communicate using
armada output just because you don't
have okay
and um kristoff just a second i'm gonna
so now you can just unmute yourself
kristoff
i think someone just accidentally came
unmuted
there we go
so so you can go pretty far especially
with
the
bslib customization but i would suggest
to stay with the with the main
the main guidelines like the main color
the main fonts and and and things like
that and and maybe some specific tweaks
but if you start to change every element
it looks like not appropriate
thank you
and i see
jay krogeman asked on the zoom chat
is there a clean way to call
a custom css or does it have to be
within a chunk in the local directory
um okay for you to jump in and add any
context there as well
yeah you can
yeah oh i just add so like the current
way that i've been solving that is like
a created a package and inside that
package inside the the inst file
i just add like a custom css file so
whenever you like go to say like okay
well let me pull down this report
template whatever it is it has that
custom css
within that uh special file right
um
is there a better way to call that in
your yaml header to where you're going
to like either a git repo
and then you're just calling that custom
css or does it always have to be in the
local directory
or no
the the css arguments support
a url so you can
you can pass a
css file that is stored online
making life painful for myself thank you
you can do that but it means that the
user will need
internet connectivity to build the slide
so
it
depends on the constraint and if you
want to share templates
you can use package and the ins but you
can also use project templates
or documents template in the package so
this is something that is supported
through the rde
the id and the armageddon draft function
where you can put rnd template with
local resource into it and when the user
wants to use the template it will copy
everything locally so that it works so
we are using that in a lot of
of the package when you are like opening
a new a new creating a new armageddon
document for example it's it's copying a
template from the install package to the
local folder yeah that's that's
currently how i have been doing it
because it will create basically an
entire folder and the css file inside
that folder i was just wondering if it
would be easier just to hey there's a
get
link that i can grab and it'll just
use that template thank you now
the other way of doing that is to have a
chunk where you download the css that
you are shared online and put that
locally
like you can do anything into a chunk
you can do anything and hide that so
usually when i'm using resource the
first time i download it i'm downloading
it and after that it's local
okay that i don't download every time
i'm rendering
thank you
thank you i just want to take a quick
break in the q a um to let you know
about a survey that the rstudio team
is launching to get feedback from
people like you all so i just want to
pass it over to nick warren to share
that as well
thanks rachel and a great presentation
kristoff hi everyone my name is nick
warren and i do product design here at
rstudio we want to invite you to join us
in completing a brief user research
survey related to how you leverage our
markdown the goal of this survey is to
better understand your use cases and
workflows and help us validate our
hypotheses around some new features
we're developing the survey has nine
questions and takes about two minutes to
complete and will be open for about 24
hours from the end of the meetup
i'm going to post the link to the survey
in the chat now
hopefully you can see that okay
and i'll personally be reading your
responses and look forward to look and
i'm looking forward to hearing what you
have to say
also huge shout out to kelly o'brien and
the rest of the r studio team for their
awesome work with all of us
thanks a lot
thanks so much nick
okay so going back over to some of the
questions in slido
i see there's an anonymous question on
how to adjust the html page margin and
break in multiple pages
um i'm not sure if this was answered
with page down or not
um
it can you can um
[Music]
so
page imaging
and page break is really
is that we
[Music]
sorry okay it's okay um that that we
have for paginated html so page done is
definitely an answer if you need to do
um
if you need to do a specific
customization mainly because a web page
doesn't really have the concept of page
margin just a main page with with
content in it so
page break is something that you can do
and and and if you look at the
armageddon documentation you will see
there is a special command like slash
page break that you can use to create a
page break but if you want to have
really page margin with some content in
the margin the tools to use would be
page done
thank you very much and
quick question um about the github link
you shared i see a few uh comments in
the chat that people were getting a 404
error okay yeah
still private i need to make that open
perfect
[Music]
i'll do that just after yeah definitely
you can do it after and i'll share that
with you i'm recording um and the link
slides as well
i saw other questions about the rmd
document i use for example there is two
examples that i included as documents so
you will have the link and it will be in
the in the published presentation so
when the link will be shared you will be
able to download
the rmd and the and the
output of what i presented
thank you
um
artemio asked a question
um which was on slide 17 that you showed
where you had the custom yaml header
is this savable as in our markdown
template or is it easier to save with a
custom
css file or other method
uh you can send dsf
yeah you can save that the yaml header
you can if you are using always the same
you can definitely put that into a rmd
template and and you would use the same
template for each of your reports
but with our magdon you can also put the
output key in an external file
uh which would be underscore
output.among
and if you have that in the same
directory as your rmd document it will
be
it will and you don't have an output key
in your r d document it will this one
will be used so you can
no i think we just lost your audio for
one second
you can use this external file in your
different uh document so if you are
using bootstrap and and you want to use
this lemon key uh this would be a wet
the way to go but it's also we are not
completely satisfied with the system so
it's why we are working and thinking
about
about also something else to share
across documents
also because this can only be used in
bootstrap-based html document and not
like for example you wouldn't be able to
use that in sharing and presentation
you kristoff
uh john i see you asked a question can
we create custom engines for our
markdown and is there documentation or
tips on it
it's um it's an opportunity question
because it's
it does not really he
has nothing to do specifically with with
styling and theming but you can create
a custom engine for knitter
so
so it's not really for our markdown
unless you are talking about custom
output formats but for
for it would be for anita you can create
custom engine that would be a like
documentation is quite sparse on that
because it's quite advanced and i think
it would be in the neither book but the
nita book was the first book from ua and
it's not free
so you will need to buy it i guess
and
and but it's documented in in the
website documentation from it are in
the website of guitar and you can find
some example in the package and that
would be the best documentation to look
at the custom engine
inside knit our package
thank you
i'm not sure if this was covered in a
previous answer
but on that topic of creating new pages
how can you make a new page or section
or landscape page using word templates
for our markdown
yeah this is a tricky question
i'm not sure you can this is part of the
limitation
from penndot because penndot doesn't
support that
so we need to check and try because
maybe they have evolved on that but
if you have
this kind of tweaks the
officer package and affiliate the office
verse packages would be
would be the way to go because you would
be able to
to modify the layout of the page but i
don't think you can using our markdown
which is using pembac
so this is part of the current
limitation
thank you
the next question is do you have any
elaborate bootstrap for examples to
reference
uh you the the main example like uh
for html document or for
for
any type of output like you you would
find the the main example you could find
would be the bs4 book format which is
used in uh
in the in now most of the book from
oddly
so you can look at the the shiny book
the art package book the
even maybe the gg plot book is using
that and there are a lot of books now
using a bs4 book so you can see how this
look like and how people have customized
the bs4 book format to their style
and you can also find examples on the
bsc package
[Music]
package done website and the sas package
and website there are not so much
on our magdon only because
we think that it was not really
documented so the presentation was part
of making that better and so hopefully
there will be more examples by you or
anyone else creating that
and we'll definitely update everything
if we switch to using bootstrap 4 as a
default for our magnum
which is not currently the case
um thank you
julian asked in the zoom chat how is the
integration
of our markdown
with jupiter notebook
or integration of
armor of markdown in general i think
julian feel free to add some context
there as well
and
armageddon is mainly
is mainly about
like it's a similar technology as a
jupiter so
you can't really use our magnum with
jupiter and you can't really use
jupiter with armageddon but you can use
rn piton
python in our magdalen and you can use
rn python in jupiter so
there is a function to convert between
the two like it's kind of experimental
but it's it's working
and there are some tools i think in the
python ecosystem like gptex will allow
you to
to convert between between format but
our magdalene won't like
maybe i didn't understand the question
but armageddon and jupiter are a bit
different but they are doing the same
thing and
and our studio is currently working of
making this a bit better at the iron
level so something similar to our magnum
but
not directly
our magnum
uh so that it can be used not only by
other users on r but
but it's still fresh so you will see
that appear in
maybe a few months i think
so but feel free to precise the question
or contact me later if i didn't
understand correctly the question
i think they may have had to drop
unfortunately but um
we'll share it through the recording too
um
i'm just gonna keep firing away a few
more questions to you if that's okay
okay yeah it's okay um so ryan asked on
zoom is css styling used for i can never
say
uh
share engine presentations
uh you you can uh yeah yeah um css the
css method and the sas tooling using the
css format can be used with any
uh html web tool any html web format
so
so sharingan is just using a specific
library called remark.js but it will
produce html so you can use css to style
a sharing gun presentation and you can
do pretty advanced stuff
you you will be able to look at the
source code of the presentation i've
made i don't know if it's the best
example because i'm tweaking a lot of
things but i'm definitely using scss to
add style and some
utility class and and other tools but
you can use any web tools with sharing
gun so so yes css styling is used for
trying that you won't be able to use the
yaml
uh styling
because it's it's used by um bslib only
and bootstrap so
the sharing gun is okay
you say that much better than me
next question is how can we generate
equation number and label in word
documents like in latex
uh this is the features that you can
find in book done package
the the referencing of equation and the
labeling of equation can be found in the
in the booked on package and and either
if you are using if you want to use a
book format but you can also
there is a format called word underscore
documents too uh we'll have we which
will have the features so best thing to
do is to go to the
to the
book documentation and and you will find
a part about word document and
and this maybe i can paste the link if i
find it quick
this will be here
yeah
and while you're sharing that too um
one question that i'd love to ask to the
audience too is someone asked are there
some good books for css and sas
feel free to share it
in the chat as well yeah
i mean i'm interested also basically i
learned css
on the go while trying to customize like
i'm not a web developer at first uh
as it was said in my background i'm an
engineer in the first place and so i i
went through code using r and and i
learned like by by doing mainly and for
css and sas uh at the end the
documentation that the shiny team made
for bslib and sas was really useful so
you can also start
there
and
and it's possible there is some
interesting information on the recent
shiny book
different shiny book there is several
shiny books that are going out and often
there is part about styling and maybe
part about css so
but if you have some good book i'm
interested also
thank you um a few
questions left i see nico you just asked
in the zoom chat um can you embed html
output with plotly graphs in an email
um
i don't really know for sure this would
be something
to try with the blastula package this is
the package that's allowed to write rmd
and
embed it to image but the difficult part
is that if you want to embed something
into an email
um everything needs to be contained into
the email and block is pretty big so
so
i don't know if this possible but really
i don't know the answer so it could be
some from some
from a colleague of mine but you should
like try with the blastula package and
and
if it doesn't work look into the issue
or ask the question in the community
and
and which will
surely
answer to you
aaron i see you had some feedback
there on
um most email servers will not display
javascript
yeah yeah that's my experience i think
the the suggestion of using blasphemous
how to do a jpeg is right you can attach
an html file but somebody will have to
open a browser which is hard on your
phone so
oh yeah okay
um the the right way to do that is
probably to link to something
elsewhere and then use a jpeg via
blastula to get stuff captured
thank you and hi aaron nice to see you
all right
um another uh question we have a few
maybe time for three more
um what would be the right best
practices to follow while creating
business reports in powerpoint using our
markdown
um
it's
the
you
you can do that using armageddon it will
be
you you need to keep a simple report
because there is not a lot of
customization that you can do like
usually when you are doing a powerpoint
slide in powerpoint manually you would
do a lot of tweaks eventually place
components in different places
when you are using a tool like
armageddon to create those you will need
to
[Music]
to keep
a fixed layout on things like have a
three to four template slide like a one
main slide main layout or two colon
layout things like that and stay with
that in the whole presentation
and and i try to keep it simple but
basically this is also something that we
are interested
in feedbacks from because
it may not be as easy to do that and and
we have uh improved during the summer as
i said
working with someone from the penndot
team so
it won't work as best as it should right
now but it will uh hopefully come
soon into that so
so the best practice would be would be
keep it simple in your slide but it's
something that is not just for
powerpoint output i guess
but
i know i like to to tweak a lot of
things and to style a lot of things so
html i prefer html presentation
and and often print them to pdf i need
to send them to someone else
thank you kristoff and there's two other
questions left around pdfs
so one is to print pdfs using page own
you need to use a chromium-based browser
can you print multiple dynamic reports
using pdf print using shiny
and chris feel free to add any context
to
yeah you need um
uh
you can print
pdf using page done with any tool that
allows you to print html and that
support the page media rules
you need to use a chromium bs browser
because
because chrome chromium has a function
and as an api that
allows us to
to dynamically a pre
color print
on documents so in page done you have a
function that is called chrome
underscore print that will basically
open chrome
or edge
load the present note the document and
then print this but
but if you have other technology like uh
the previous technology was um
phantom gs but it's deprecated now but
they're surely other i'm guess you you
can do that
uh and from shinee you would be able to
do that for dynamic report but
you need to have the external tool
available so you need to have chromium
or you need to have this tool available
in the shiny app or in the server so
that you can call them
but but you can print dynamically
html to pdf using those kind of tool
so you should be able to do that in the
shiny app also depends after on which
server you are
deploying your application
okay and on a similar thought someone
just asked will pdf produce via css and
page js
give me the same level of control as a
latex template
it
depends how much you know about latte i
guess
uh if someone is using latex from like
10 years or more you will know a lot uh
about how to use la texan style and and
i think it can do a lot of things and
and pgs and css can be a hard step for
such person but if you don't know
latex yet maybe more interesting to
invest into css and and pgs because it
could be more towards the future and
html you can do
a lot of things and it's really powerful
but it could
it could rely on a lot of high skill but
i see the same for latex like i know
only basic about latex and and i won't
be i'm no i'm not able to make a latex
template and i think i would be able to
make a html template so
i would say yes you can do that but
but
pgs is kind of new and and it's still
new for the web and latex is here since
a
very long time and is made for
doing um pdf and doing um papers and
things like that so i guess you can do
more using latex now if you if you know
about it then if it works well for you
thank you so much and there's
one last question
that came in from the zoom chat
is how do you handle special characters
in a french document
uh
they should work like i'm french so
so i could easily debug if there is an
issue so don't hesitate to
to post on the on one of the repo but
but uh our magdon is working using um so
this kind of special character i think
is called encoding stuff and our magdan
is only using utf-8
which should support um
special character so
french character accentuated character
things like that so
so it should work but after that if you
are writing html if your document is in
html at the end
you need you you may need to tell
the browser
in the html that you are writing in
french and so for that you need to add
an attribute which is
like seeing this one
i'm posting in the
doom site in the ammo
this one to change the length weight of
html but this is a html thing so
this would this would not work for pdf
for example i would have no usage but
for or maybe it works i don't know it is
different but
if the issue you have is in the output
maybe it's an html configuration and not
the armageddon thing but if you have
issue in
the conversion of the armageddon sign
and you get special weird character like
just open an issue and we look into that
but it should work
awesome thank you so much christoph i
know we're a little bit over but i think
we made it through all the questions
so thank you all for
your engagement and and asking all the
questions as well
also just want to say thanks for filling
out that our markdown
survey as well for the r studio team
that's really helpful and
i see that there were already 60 or so
people that completed that um so thank
you
nick if you want to share that again i
think it's just if you scroll up in the
chat it's there
um
a lot of people have asked about the
where the recording will be and the
slides um and so i will share
the recording of this up to the rstudio
youtube so you can find it there i just
have to process it right now
but should be up by the end of the day
i'll also include those links
there to the slides
on the linkedin event if you found this
event there
also on meetup.com
event if that's where you found this
but thank you all so much for joining if
you are interested in maybe speaking at
a future or studio enterprise community
meetup it doesn't have to be in the near
future but if it's something that is on
your horizon i'm going to put one more
form here
where you can submit a potential talk
abstract
just want to say thank you all it was
great to see all of you here and have a
great rest of the day
thank you christoph bye
[Music]
you